ce mal qui est avec nous madame coupal
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur je vous propose
un extrait du jugement dans la
conclusion c'est très court de deux
petits extraits que j'ai besoin de vos
lumières les problèmes de crédibilité
écrit le juge et de fiabilité sont
suffisamment inquiétant pour contaminer
l'ensemble du témoignage il est
impossible d'avoir confiance en son
témoignage où est alors il parle à ce
moment-là du plaignant et ce qu'il dit
c'est que quand ils le trouvaient
plusieurs points et le juge dans
témoignage du plaignant qui fonctionnait
pas entre autres il dit à d'exagération
il est peu fiable
il ne veut pas reconnaître ses erreurs
vous savez on a souvent dit que à
l'époque où se serait passé les
événements particuliers de l'agression
dans la chambre de bain le plaignant et
monsieur s'en va il n'aurait pas
travailler ensemble et cela a été
pratiquement prouve hélas les points
principaux alors que monsieur salvail si
je ne travaillais pas témoignages à
l'appui le tout avec ses journaux et et
l union ne voulait pas reconnaître ce
point le nom c'est moi qui a raison
alors si toutes sortes de petits détails
1 après l'eau qui fait en sorte que le
juge dumais mien je peux pas le croire
yoto de nombreux donc très sain où je
pense mais qu'il invente qu'ils fabulent
il veut tout convaincre le tribunal est
donc parce qu'il ne croit paul
plaignants et même s'il ne croit pas
éric salvant et quand il dit moi je ne l
ai jamais rencontré etc
j'ai jamais rien fait il si je n'ai pas
le choix que de lui accorder à monsieur
salvail le doute raisonnable
oui c'est tellement plus simple que la
sphère ozon parce qu'ici sans prendre de
grid analyse de juristes
on pourrait résumer en disant le juge
nous dit ce sont deux témoignages
essentiels évidemment plaignante et
l'accusé que je ne crois pas je ne bois
pas ni'lin milo alors comment appuyer un
verdict de culpabilité je peux pas voilà
le doute il s'applique
disons dans l'ensemble après autant du
côté de monsieur salvail y en a pas
autant du côté du bnia il n'y a pas de
doute non plus ce sont des versions qui
ne sont pas crédibles et pour des
raisons différentes
dans le cas de monsieur salvail ce qui a
vraiment atteint s'acquitte vite et
c'est cette contre-preuve où trois
personnes sont venues d une wii wheel à
des comportements harcelant et il est
déplacé il ya des comportements de
nature sexuelle il avait nié cei avec
moi j'ai tellement bonne réputation
genre de preuve de bonne réputation
alors ça ça tout de suite le jumeau
jeunes n'y croient pas monsieur salvat
et quant aux plaignants c'est en faisant
une analyse exhaustive des manières où
il aura les pleins de contradictions
mais surtout oui on semble le juge a un
malaise avec la fille abby la viabilité
de l'individu au lever trop là-dessus
justement en termine à madame compaq
commun ou un juge fait déterminé qu'il
ne croit pas telle partie du témoignage
ou est ce que c'est une niepce et
impressionniste où c'est vraiment des
petites contradictions des petits faits
qui s'entrechoquent japon avec les deux
ans dans ce cas ci je pense que la
question entre autres additionnel les
pop et dance est ce facile la date de
l'événement devenait important parce que
le plaignant était et n oubliez pas
bouger sur ce fait là et il y avait
aussi des contradictions importantes
peut-être jeu sur des petits faits mais
plusieurs contradictions entre les
versions du plaignant d'année au passé
ou encore donné aux policiers alors tout
ça c'est un cumul dans le cas actuel ce
n'est se séparent examen si jamais une
impression est ici on a vraiment un
jugement où on a une étude sur la
crédibilité là qui est remarquable dans
leur version ozon avait surtout ce
jugement-là une étude endroit relance
les l'évolution du droit ici c'est
vraiment des comment on fait pour
déterminer la crédibilité de 2,8 ça ne
coûte pas là ce qu'ils vont dire dans
les prochains jours pour voir la suite
certainement de l'entendre comme après
le jugement est rose en ce qu'ils vont
dire ah ben ça y est on croit jamais les
victimes qu'est ce que vous répondez
vous mangerez pas encore ce que j'ai dit
depuis des années vous savez les deux
qu'on a vu cette semaine c'est d'eux que
dont on a entendu parler on n'entend pas
parler de ce qui se passe à l'année
longue dans les palais de justice je
voudrais particulièrement montréal et
dans les grands centres au québec il y
en a des agressions sexuelles
il y en a beaucoup six ans qui vont
devant les tribunaux il ya beaucoup
d'accusés qui sont déclarés coupables et
dans bien des cas aussi la présomption
d'innocence continue à port le doute
raisonnable il ya des acquittements
et si le format peu juste et cela
seulement pour ne pas envoyer on le
répète des innocents en prison suzanne
coupal que la retraite merci beaucoup
nous avons parlé un peu plaisir mais
foire